so
footwork with the joe the footwork with
the joe footwork with the ken
both the same today i'm wearing a heavy
pair of boots
they're walking boots and uh
especially when any of you who do walk
you'll know that
perhaps you know you've had a busy day
or even
on a long walk the legs get really heavy
and you're
basically going to mount him walking or
up
steep paths that's a separate hobby
isn't it
not really you can use your aikido in
daily life like cochita
said you can use your hips to walk with
and not your feet
so the idea is to use your hips
this is the feet walking
[Music]
this is the feet
i'm filming this today on a quite a
steep incline
to show you that with the feet walking
it gets
backwards or forwards it's quite heavy
you have to dig
into your car
[Music]
use your hips
now i wasn't putting it on the first one
if you thought that i was
making difficult work
my hips are instructing my legs
so if you can uh
today's easter easter day and everybody
is
the sun shining everybody's out enjoying
yourself motorbikes cars
walkers so this is this is life
this is real life so hope
that's not putting you off too much and
uh
use your eyes as well as your ears
to see what i'm doing and try to put
that into yourself
so i'm using my hips backwards
i'm using my hips going forwards
i'm going to do some joe work now
make your body move and while i was
doing that
i wasn't thinking about the joe
movements at all i was thinking about
my my hips because my
hips are the control panel and they're
controlling the feet and where the feet
need to go the feet need to float
you need them to float across the ground
so when training
heavier the items on your ankles and
feet
the better
[Music]
try to get some heavy ankle weights
put them on train on the mat or
in the park or in your garden
and use the weight around your ankles
until you can not feel the weight
[Music]
um
on the 13 carter since i've got the joe
when locking don't just lift your arms
up here
this is only good for
receiving a ski
if it's too straight at coming up
if somebody was to do a showman your
joe or their joe would break because
it's
it's come up in a sort of circle but see
this part here
it starts with a circle
and then goes straight straight starts
with a circle but then
seems to go straight so from a showman
strike
there joe or george i would break
if you've ever ridden the most bike gave
me the thought when i heard the
motorbikes go by
if you've ever ridden a map where you
twist the throttle like this
on a motorbike you need that idea that
action
in both hands so you
roll it like that so it goes out
but the roll of the hands now
the roll of the hands so that if you had
a showman strike
it would be
[Music]
another breakdown
so the 13 car to the first
two blocks need to be like twisting
twisting a throttle on a motorbike but
both
both hands and this is your exercise
for the day feet and hands
[Music]
oh